plus de deux mille personnes seraient en
marche derrière emmanuel macron dans le
département des yvelines
le mouvement a organisé ce samedi 15
octobre à versailles une réunion
publique
objectif faire une restitution partielle
des deux premiers meetings de l'ancien
ministre de l'économie pour présenter le
diagnostic de la grande marche
cette initiative qui a permis d'aller
rencontrer les français reparler tu peux
des thèmes qu'emmanuel a lancé les
pistes de réflexion et sur lesquels
aujourd'hui nos nos compatriotes
yvelinois vont nous donner leur avis
director cette grande marche a mis en
évidence deux thèmes prioritaires pour
les français leur vie quotidienne et
leur engagement
ben moi ce que j'aime bien c'est un il
fait appel à l'intelligence des monts
intelligente des indigents et français
et puis de il compte beaucoup sur
l'implication des citoyens
initialement je suis pas venu pour
m'approcher lui parce que c'était un
mouvement qui enfin à les écouter les
français
plutôt que de réfléchir tout seul et
puis ensuite de proposer des choses et
j'espère vraiment qu'il va se présenter
parce qu'il a il ya une puissance une
intelligence est quelqu'un qui s'est
énormément travaillé reste une question
d'envergure emmanuel macron sera-t-il
candidat à l'élection présidentielle de
la candidature elle est secondaire ce
qui compte c est ce que le projet que
nous allons construire
il sera en phase ou pas avec le pays et
pour le construire nous souhaitons faire
avec les gens donc prendre le temps de
le faire
l'ancien conseiller économique de
françois hollande tient ce mardi 18
octobre son dernier meeting à
montpellier
il proposera ensuite ses solutions